[Music]
so i get these videos all the time since
we've been reacting to different videos
on social media on tick tock and
instagram and i'll get dms or tagged at
least 10 times a day wow on random
videos where they go you gotta debunk
this you gotta reach oh i like this and
so there's this one particular video
that has just been nagging me i get it
at least once a week for the last three
months so i thought we'd play it for our
viewers and listeners and what you're
gonna see in this video is a woman
talking about 401ks and how terrible
they are is this a financial expert of
some sort we have no idea oh we don't
even know no one knows it's the internet
ken oh it's just an interview and so
below that is a guy reacting to her
video oh and he's pointing in agreement
and i know who this guy is so we'll talk
about it after all right let's let's
let's get it guys let's watch this
401k was never meant as a big retirement
plan a 401k was developed because after
the depression
people were not getting back into the
stock market so they created a 401k to
make it easy for the average person to
get into the stock market so you really
got to
do some rese i mean everybody all of us
need to really do our research when
we're looking at just blindly accepting
advice from somebody
so i don't think today you can save
yourself to retirement i mean the
interest rate's two percent right it was
it was almost negative because it was
zero something and the fees you're
paying is brings you negative
um so if you're saving money
are you trying to build as big a nest
egg as possible to live off of and who
knows what's going to happen with
inflation deflation
there's so many factors so i don't think
saving and a 401k is a good financial
retirement plan at all
okay now can i just the musical lady
epic
so dramatic yes right and he was very
excited with the finger pointing and the
touching of the ear yeah but i want to
go back to the lady the so-called expert
who says
uh you got to do your research and did i
hear her i want to make sure i heard
this because i was i was doing my own
research on the google while she was
talking about research it doesn't take
much googling to figure out didn't she
say that it was two percent on the 401k
she said a lot of things though okay so
for the lady who said you need to do
your research
while she was blathering on
i pulled it up
and uh the average rate of return on
401ks just over uh five years from 250
2015 2020 was nine and a half percent
there we go so i found that on the
google on my favorite podcast
immediately she's talking about how
after the great depression 401ks no
401ks didn't come about until 1978 and
it got popular in the early 1980s again
i don't know what research you're
talking about research lady needs to
take her own financial history class
goodness gracious see this is why and
again i'm not trying to bang on this
this this this this expert but
this is why we got to be careful what we
consume sure somebody put her out there
and she's she's she's saying nonsense
well can i tell you i know this guy
flips it and then he goes
what was this move that's the new move
by the way james when somebody says
something i like
uh next time i'm on with dave co-hosting
with dave he's gonna say something great
he has no context of this clip and i'm
gonna go
there we go just point up in the air
like dave's right listen or maybe i
should point this way
anyway i digress i know too much ken
what do you know about this guy the
reason this video has taken off and it's
been reacted to so many times with
people in agreement yeah guess what
industry all of those people are in
oh
life insurance oh
so the um bait and switch here's the
here's the connecting point all of these
people uh either sell permanent life
insurance indexed universal life
insurance you name it all insurances
that we know
are garbage okay stop right there we
have a lot of new people like record
numbers of new people watching listening
all the time why do we think that those
products are garbage george because they
are astronomically more expensive than
term life
and it's trying to do two things at once
it's trying to be insurance and an
investment which is how these policies
are touted they're touted by all these
guys as this is a way better investment
than your 401k your 401ks trash you
should invest with me in this whole life
policy
uh in order to make money and so that
guy in the bottom of the video is an
index universal life insurance salesman
of course and on his website on his his
academy he sells it says index universal
life insurance is without debate the
best choice for secure compounding
so that's the promise they're making and
which why they're all railing on
against the 401k and here's what we
found in our millionaire study ken 10
000 of them 79
of them reach millionaire status through
their employer-sponsored retirement
plans right so this lady saying 401k's
terrible what about inflation and she's
just trying to fear monger people away
from doing a wise investment into hey
put your money with me and index
universal life insurance and you'll be
way better off it is such a nonsensical
statement to say that 401ks were not
meant to help people with retirement
it's just it's literally like saying
uh
i don't even know i can't even think of
something so stupid because it's like
it's the whole purpose it is an
investment fund and it allows you to
invest and as you said the real numbers
from the largest millionaire study
that's ever been done ramsey solutions
says that it works and it works over and
over again and again
let me give this further
some real skin on this thing the third
largest group of millionaires net worth
millionaires from this study were
teachers
now you look at that's all you have to
say but you look at the median income of
teachers in the united states right now
you're looking at about 65 68 000 i
believe it is um it might be 60. it's
one of those three for all your fact
checkers out there so i've got your
someone will do this but the point is is
in that range of income
you are making enough money to invest in
a retirement account like a 401k and
absolutely retire with tremendous
dignity and we live a very full life and
we've seen it over and over time and
time again baby steps millionaires are
being created because they follow our
plan baby step forward invest 15 of your
household income into retirement
accounts like 401ks and iras roth is
even better so i think what's happening
here ken is a lot of the younger
generations they're poo pooing all of
these old boring antiquated investment
vehicles like 401ks and iras and they're
trying to take shortcuts and get tricky
and go hey if i do this and get this
indexed universal life policy and some
crypto man i'll be way better off yeah
but as we're seeing where are all the
index universal life millionaires right
i haven't met them yeah go poopoo that
you said you said
i did
i knew you'd like that well i like the
emphasis on that it gave it a little
extra panic thank you